so Tom it's lovely to see you here today
for crossing lines and of course your
fans who Nev as jaqen H'ghar in game of
thrones how would you describe your
character in crossing lines in the show
it's a bit different I'm not wearing a
wig for and know my characters Sebastian
Sebastian burger is from the Berlin
police originally and now he works for
our team which is based in The Hague at
the International Criminal Court and
it's basically a special task force a
team of cops that pursue criminals
across borders it's a bit like the FBI
in in the states that was founded so
police could go after the bad guys
across state borders and well even
though it doesn't exist in reality yet
in Europe I'm sure it certainly will it
at some point your character in the show
is a bit of a tech genius yes that
required a good chair of acting I know
where to turn the computer on and I know
where to turn it off and everything that
happens in between is a big mystery to
me so when you're having to describe
stuff in the language the the ESP uses
well how do you find that it's it's
that's actually it's the trickiest part
about this project because sometimes I'm
I'm I'm having tech dialogue that I
would even have difficulty and
difficulties understanding in German let
alone English and so and I really have
to learn those lines and find out what
they mean to know what I'm talking about
you know of course you've been filming
in Prague for this aren't even filming
in Paris as well in the South of France
tell me what that was like well it's
it's it's part of the
the great experience on this project is
that we get to go different places on
there definitely worse places to spend
six months of your life and in Prague in
Paris I it's it's they're great cities
and so it's especially nice when you
have a day off that even when you're in
a nice city in Prague so it's really
beautiful I mean I don't know if I know
it from when I was growing up because I
grew up in in Germany but very close to
the Czech border so we would go to
Prague all the time and it's it's it's
really changed like all the old
buildings have been renovated and it's I
mean it's almost like if if what Disney
had invented the city it would have been
proud so it's almost too pretty
sometimes now you got a multinational
cars to this it's not a great cars how
many what it's what's it like kind of
fitting in with gonna working with
different people in different places
well it's a really interesting
experience and that's one one point that
really got me attracted to the show
because you you meet as you said you
meet so many different people from
different countries with different
backgrounds different approaches to
acting so it's a very it's like it's
like a bit of a melting pot our set so
and but it's fun and yeah
I mean especially working with great
actors like Donald Sutherland William
Fichtner I mean it's it's it's a really
cool experience I mean how do you I mean
I believe the second season is already
in production know and how's that going
it's going well I mean we've we've shot
two episodes I'm we're doing 12 and
total no first season was 10 and we
started shooting in Bulgaria and I went
back in Prague and then we'd be going to
Marseilles and Monaco very no complaints
they're definitely getting well travel
don't you with this now how do you
envisage your character develop
in season two and how do you visit a
show developing as well what I like
about the show I mean it's a it's a it's
a crime show definitely so we are
solving we solve cases but at the same
time there's a lot of horizontal
storytelling so you find out a lot about
the characters and it's not just your
your regular police guys heroes the good
guys bringing down the bad guys it's
like it's very complex characters and of
the course of the season the audience
will find out that all of us have dark
sides to our characters problems and so
that's what I find very intriguing it's
what got me interested in the show in
the first place and also because roll up
our the the producer and Ed Byrne era
the showrunner they asked us before we
started shooting they asked us for our
input and they asked us how we would our
characters like to develop and so that
that's good I mean as an actor you
actually have the the feeling that
you're working together on a project as
normally you would just get a script and
that has been approved by the network
and you would shoot that script but here
you can actually give some input and
develop the characters oh that's
fantastic it makes it a more
collaborative experience this must be
absolutely brilliant now I've got to ask
you also here I mentioned Jack him
before your fans would kill me if I
didn't ask you about it so playing Game
of Thrones and what do you think about
the theory that Syrio Forel and Jack and
Hogan are one and the same person how
many minutes do we have do you know what
I haven't really thought about that I
know that the theory exists
I don't think Jack and in Syria are the
same person
but I haven't had the chance to talk to
George Martin so I have no idea really
would you like him to be or would I like
Jack and to be the serial doesn't matter
does it really I mean since
since both characters are very unique
and very different I mean I wouldn't
mind if they were the same character but
I mean I I just play dragon now if you
could change your character well like he
can he would you like to change into a
what would you like to change if you
could be anybody who would you be any
other character any one character or
anyone in life yeah I think I'd like to
stage a can and come back yeah we'd like
to be and be the last one on the Iron
Throne
[Laughter]
absolutely I think that's I mean that's
the natural but that'd be the natural
thing definitely well he doesn't want to
sit on the Iron Throne head down to the
day definitely how did he find it
talking about yourself in the third
person also I'm a man so this among says
that I quite like you though yeah when I
had to do the audition though when I did
the addition of I hadn't hadn't heard
about Game of Thrones so I just got that
that scene and I loved it and I thought
what is this in a guy who talks himself
in the third person I mean no idea how
to do that and but it's and I've come to
I've come to realize that it's like one
of his like special things and which
kind of it's it's already a very strong
would you say that it's a very strong
characteristic characteristic so it it's
part of the the portray of the character
already so there it was a big help and
he's a man of mystery isn't he how
mysterious would you say you are in real
life
I don't know by the scale of 1 to 10
mystery man o Lords it depends on the
occasion that it's mysterious I'm giving
you maybe an eight for that we'll see
you again on the show I have no idea I
mean George Martin still
writing I forgot to call him have to
have to talk to him yeah pick up the
phone this is he definitely have you
watched it at all since since you left
yeah you have what was your reading
reaction well the thing unfortunately I
knew in a way what was coming or that
something was coming it's an amazing
it's an amazing episode and yeah it's
the way they filmed it I thought was
unbelievable really great I also enjoyed
all the all the videos and YouTube about
people's reactions to that now if you
tell us what your most striking moments
were in both Game of Thrones and also in
crossing aligns striking moments well I
think it's it's it's the whole
experience of being on a big set with a
multinational cast it it's just both of
both shows are big enterprises and it's
it's really fun to be part of that what
are your best memories from the filming
of both shows Game of Thrones I'd say
the costume stuff like this being able
to to live in a different century or in
a different time period in a medieval
setting with all the with all the extras
on set and everybody in mail and and
armor and so that you feel kind of
beamed into into a different life of
course I call it very interesting death
your character came back whenever throws
a new hat to die how would you like to
see him go out I don't think I don't
think Jack and could die could he you
could just change into someone else
couldn't exactly
you